so rachel levine the male health
secretary of pennsylvania who identifies
as a female
and who headed up the pandemic response
in in that state which was
clumsy and disastrous and led to
thousands of elderly deaths in nursing
homes like in new york
uh pennsylvania also sent
infected people into nursing homes on
purpose just like new york did
but we're going to reward this person
with a a position
um just purely on the basis of
of identity politics of course rachel
levine
had a hearing in the senate on thursday
and at least one senator stepped up
that would be rand paul to take him to
task for
his support of drugging and mutilating
gender confused children
a position that would be totally
disqualifying in a sane and healthy
country you know
it's it's if you have that position
where you're in favor of drugging and
mutilating confused
children um that should qualify you for
a mental institution
or prison not for a position in
government
but as we've been talking about this is
this is we're looking at the
enshrinement of insanity
a war on reality which is what the
democrats have been waging for some time
now
that's nothing new so uh rand paul
questioned levine and um couldn't get a
straight answer but let's let's watch
some of this let's
let's watch rand paul at least make an
attempt
you know give it the old college try to
get an answer out of rachel levine
uh where when it comes to you know
mutilating children
and what should the policy be with
gender confused children here it is
let's watch
dr levine you have supported both
allowing minors to be given hormone
blockers
to prevent them from going through
puberty as well as surgical destruction
of a minor's genitalia
like surgical mutilation hormonal
interruption of puberty can permanently
alter and prevent secondary sexual
characteristics
the american college of pediatricians
reports that 80 to 95 percent
of pre-pubertal children with gender
dysphoria will
experience resolution by late
adolescents if
not exposed to medical intervention and
social affirmation
dr levine do you believe that minors are
capable of making such a life-changing
decision as changing one's sex
well senator thank you for your interest
in this question transgender medicine
is a very complex and nuanced field
with robust research and standards of
care that have been developed
and if i am fortunate enough to be
confirmed as the assistant secretary of
health i will look forward to working
with you
and your office and coming to your
office and discussing the
particulars of the standards of care for
transgender medicine
so this is the old uh you got to pass
the bill to find out what's in it
in this case we're being told you got
you got to confirm
the nominee to find out what they
actually think about this issue
because the response that rand paul gets
we'll play the next clip yet because he
again we'll play the next clip in a
second because he makes another attempt
but
the response is well why don't you
confirm me and then we'll
all come to your office and we can talk
about it no why don't you talk about it
now this is a very simple question
very easy question of course we already
know the answer to it
because we have rachel levine's previous
uh statements on this subject and he's
been very clear about it
we already know the answer to it and if
we didn't already know the answer we'd
know it now
because you know when you're asked um do
you support
genital mutilation of gender confused
children
and drugging them when you're asked that
that it's if you answer anything but
hell
no what are you crazy of course not
any answer outside of that tells me that
your real answer is yes
and you don't belong anywhere in
government or anywhere in civilized
society
this is this is one of those issues and
there are several of them
but this is certainly one where if you
ever
you know if you're more on the the
moderate in the middle kind of person
um and you you may be a little confused
about who the real bad guys are
and i'm not going to sit here and tell
you that the republicans are heroes
courageous heroes
they're far from it um i think lan
i i like rand paul i think rand paul is
great
but i'm not going to tell you
republicans are in general
there are clear bad guys though and if
you ever get confused about it
if you need to be reminded then go back
and watch this exchange again
because there is one political party
that supports drugging and mutilating
children children who are are simply
confused
as all children are it's very normal for
a child to be confused
and of course a child is going to be
confused about something like
biological sex if he's not given
explanations
you know if a child at the age of four
is you know
a four-year-old boy starts saying oh i
think i'm a girl
if at that moment
his parents and his teachers if he's in
school and
his doctors if they all say to him oh no
no no no no little johnny you're
you're not a girl you're a boy
or you could even ask him why do you why
do you say that why do you why do you
say you're a girl
that's a really simple question if you
get any kind of answer at all from the
four-year-old
i guarantee it is going to be something
along the lines of um
he likes to play with dolls and he
thinks that
that pink dresses are pretty something
like that
and because in his little four-year-old
brain you know he that's
that's what he thinks a girl is he
doesn't know he doesn't
actually know what a boy or girl is at
the age of four
or five or six they don't really
understand
what what that means so that little
child
he's that's that's all he's drawing an
association
he's noticing he's perceptive and he's
noticing that generally
uh the the people that the adults call
girls are
you know they have the pink stuff and
the dolls and everything and
the the people the adult the grown-ups
call boys they
wear the blue and the darker colors and
they like trucks and so if that
four-year-old boy is going through a
phase where you know he's a little bit
more interested in the dolls big deal
who cares
fine what he's going to say is
oh i am a girl he doesn't know what that
means because he's four what he actually
means is i
am interested in these things which i
associate with girls
and sane decent adults
will respond to that by saying okay
great you want to play with a dog go
play with a doll it doesn't matter
fine you're still a boy though
the child gets that kind of response
from his parents
from you know all the adults in his life
he'll be fine
he'll he'll get over this phase of
calling himself a girl in a few weeks
if not if not right that second
but if the child is told um
oh well if you say you're a girl then
maybe you are
and if he's told this by all of the
adults in his life we trust then of
course he's going to be confused
who wouldn't be
fast forward a few years and now we're
gonna drug that child
by the way another thing we'll hear this
from rand paul in a second
just so you know um when when
the left says that puberty blockers
and all these hormone treatments and
hormone pills and stuff
given to children when the left says
that that it's safe
that there are no long-term side effects
they are lying
they are lying through their teeth
either they are speaking out of
ignorance
or they are straight up lying
because the fact is number one it is
definitely not safe
you're using this this medication off
label you're using medication that was
not made to be to be given to children
who are physically healthy
you are stunting intentionally their
normal physical growth
that is by definition not safe in terms
of all of the long-term consequences
we don't know now a rational person can
guess can assume that there are going to
be a number
of of any number of serious physical
emotional psychological long-term
effects
but in terms of the full extent of it we
don't know because this
we are we talk about experiments we're
running experiments on a whole
generation of kids right now
we don't know what it's going to look
like in 30 years democrats will just
lie and they'll say oh it's safe we
already know it they don't know that
what they mean is well we hope it's
probably said we hope it's safe and uh
so we'll find out what we'll use these
kids as guinea pigs and we'll check back
in 30 years
see how destroyed their life their lives
are
unless they've killed themselves by then
as a as as
the rimer twins did john money's victims
all right let's go back to uh rand paul
he's makes another attempt to get an
answer out of rachel levine here it is
for most of our history we believe that
minors don't have full rights and the
parents need to be involved
so i'm alarmed that you won't say with
certainty that minors should not have
the ability
to make the decision to take hormones
that will affect them for the rest of
their life
will you make a more firm decision on
whether or not minors should be involved
in these decisions
senator transgender medicine is a very
complex
and nuanced field and if confirmed to
the position of assistant secretary of
health
i would certainly be pleased to come to
your office and talk with you and your
staff
about the standards of care and the
complexity of this field
let it go into the record that the
witness refused to answer the question
the question is a very specific one
should minors be making these momentous
decisions for most of the history of
medicine
we wouldn't let you have a cut sewn up
in the er but you're willing to let a
minor take things that prevent their
puberty
and you think they get that back you
give a woman testosterone enough that
she grows a beard you think she's gonna
go back looking like a woman when you
stop the testosterone
you have permanently changed them
rand paul is exactly right of course um
and he got a lot of grief from the left
for calling genital mutilation genital
mutilation what the hell else do you
call it
you're taking a physically healthy
person uh
you know a girl chopping their breasts
off
what else do you call about mutilation
this is if this is a physically healthy
person
or you know a male and
doing a lot of incisions and cutting and
things to to to fashion their
their male reproductive organs to look
like
some approximation of female genitals
what
what else do you call about mutilation
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matte wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content